these questions from Brenda in
California how do I proceed when
collection agencies have not responded
to my debt validation and settlement
letter it has been over a month you can
call them if you want then just say I
sent you a letter asking for debt
validation and a settlement and just
checking for follow-up if you want
here's the thing you'll find the problem
is there are a few and I mean a very few
collectors and collection agencies that
are competent the vast majority of them
have the person sitting in the chair
calling you has a lifespan of under 90
days on the job they don't keep their
jobs and the reason is it's such a
horrible freaking job to call people all
day long and be nasty it's just very
difficult for most people to do that and
so the turnover and plus most of the
collection agencies lie and they break
federal law and they do all these other
things that people with ethics can't
abide and they just you know again there
are a few good ones and most of them are
your local small town collection agency
where they do abide by the Federal Fair
Debt Collection Practices Act and there
may be somebody that's actually in the
Chamber of Commerce they may go to your
local church they might be reasonable
human beings but the rest of them are
scum and they you know the what you do
if you run a large boiler room
collection agency is you hire and train
all the time because you have to replace
the revolving door that is your front
door they come in and they go out they
come in they go out because as soon as
they can find a job making less money
they'll leave because it's just such a
horrible job and it is on so that that's
what you're dealing with is the you know
the bottom of the Darwyn curve is who's
on the phone because the number one they
took this job in the first place
it means they were desperate for a job
and if they stayed there a long time now
you got double uh because that's
starting to make a statement about the
person you're talking to or they've just
been there 20 minutes and you know more
than they know and that's what you
usually find so it just takes a while
it's a very frustrating process to
negotiate with and deal with collection
agencies see this is your money you owe
money for something someone did for you
or gave you this is your personal
business the person on the other end
it's just their job and they're in a
cubicle with a headset on and they
hadn't been there long and that's what
you've got to remember especially if one
of them starts being nasty to you know
that stuff because they teach them the
nasty technique the first day right and
because it works people get all
intimidated too scared and shaky and
freaked out and they'll give you their
mother's house you know just to get you
off the phone and you know because
people just don't do conflict well
anymore unless it's you know they don't
do well then the place they've got any
bravery is on Twitter but in real life
people don't do conflict well because
they're scared and so that they use this
intimidation tactic in the collections
world because it works and if you start
getting that here's a neat idea just go
hey you've got about five seconds to
turn that crap off and we're going to
talk like to regular people or you're
gonna be talking to a dial tone what you
have to break any blink-blink you're
gonna hang up on me yep dink you're gone
just like that I push the little end
button right here on my phone and you
will end it's over
I ended you and that's you know you just
got to move on and go back and try to
find one occasionally that for a second
will rub two brain cells together and
try to help you but it's a frustrating
process